Speaker 1: So the search continues for the
believed Mar a Lago trader slash, mall slash,
leak or whatever. This is the story, the
belief wherein there are some in the MAGA,
right. Who believe that the only way the FBI could
have known where to look and what to do during
this search warrant would have been if there
were some mole within MAGA land. And many names
have been floated, everything from some Secret
Service agent to some employee at Mar a Lago,
all the way to Mark Meadows. Now, I don't know
for sure that it's clear there is such a mole,
because there are also claims that Donald Trump
personally gave FBI agents a tour of Mar a Lago
some months ago and might even have
shown them exactly where everything is.
We just don't know if there is a so-called mole
at Mar a Lago. But increasingly there are reports
that Donald Trump is being driven nuts. That's
a quote driven nuts not knowing who the mole is,
according to an ex federal prosecutor and others
have made similar claims. And one of the things
that is being made very, very clear by Donald
Trump's lawyer, Eliana Haber, is that. They're
going to find who the mole is. They're going to
figure out who it is. And then all bets are off
another one of these thinly veiled threats. Take
a listen to Olena Haba appearing on I believe this
is on Newsmax and it's the typical mob speak that
we've become very accustomed to in the Trump era.
Speaker 2: The President's position, the same as
what I would advise him is to ask them to uncover
everything so that we can see what is going
on. I understand the witness protection issue,
but at the same time, these witnesses are truly
not going to be concealed for very long. That's
just not the nature of the DOJ and the FBI.
Speaker 1: They're going to figure out who you
are eventually. This is the typical mob speak that
we've gotten accustomed to from Trumpists. This
is either just more insanity or a warning, a
threat to the informant if they even exist.
How are they supposed? Listen, Elina Harbor
wants to know, how do we intimidate a witness
when we don't know who the witness is? We need
to be told who that witness is. And there is no
question whatsoever that if there is such a mole
and if indeed their identity becomes public,
that the MAGA Trump right. Is going
to go absolutely nuts. I mean, listen,
they're going after FBI agents. Merrick Garland
is receiving death threats. Christopher Wray, who
was selected to run the FBI by Trump, who signed
off on the search warrant. He is getting death
threats. These people are vicious. These people
are violent. January 6th, prove that to us. And
so I understand the concern if such a mole exists.
I understand why they would rather not be known.
And everybody in MAGA world is melting down.
And that's what I want to talk about next.